les fêtes des mobilisations qui a existé
là aussi je crois que la victoire de la
gauche et du parti socialiste ce soir
s'explique en grande partie par une
démotivation campagne très longue les
primaires socialistes l'élection
présidentielle un manque d'explications
aussi probablement donc françois patriat
disais à l'instant il faut reconnaître
sa défaite c'est une défaite nationale
c'est une vague rose même on peut le
dire plus importante que 2007 dans
l'autre sens
c'est raison pour laquelle je vous
n'avez pas eu votre tva sociale non on a
fait notre tva sociale mais on n'avait
rien d'éléments n'y a pas eu d'éléments
qui a notoirement modifier la baie on a
une anecdote mais dont je ne parlerai
pas ce soir qui tenait plus de la
boutade mais paix à son âme
l'une d'une des candidats de visée n'est
plus ne sera pas au perchoir demain donc
simplement la côte-d'or a bien résisté
je crois qu on le constate c'est que
j'ai une pensée pour bernard depierre je
disais tout à l'heure mais il n'empêche
que aussi bien rémi delattre aussi bien
françois sauvadet ou si bien pascal
caravelle qui a fait un très beau score
sur la troisième dans le contexte actuel
et je parle pas de moi même ces accords
on a aujourd'hui la preuve que quand on
est sur le territoire lorsqu on apporte
des solutions concrètes au niveau de
l'emploi du développement économique ce
sont des choses qui portent simplement
c'est vrai que la bourgogne en elle-même
ce soir la bourgogne de l'ump est un pur
deuil notamment en ce qui concerne la
saône et loire dans la nièvre j'en parle
pas je la connais bien je pense que ce
n'était pas une grande victoire en tous
les cas la part de la gauche de
conquérir la nièvre il avait déjà co